she'll always be able to get an abortion
because she'll be able to fly to one of
what they're calling the 13 safe states
places that might continue to have
abortion like california or new york but
for a lot of vulnerable women women who
are poor women who are women women of
color they will be forced to have
pregnancies that they cannot afford to
terminate and pregnancies that will then
turn into children
[Music]
pregnancies that will then
turn into children
is there anything worse is there
anything that a woman
doesn't want to hear when they're
pregnant oh my it might turn into a baby
a child we got to play this thing again
the insanity before i even say hello to
be able to get an abortion because
you'll be able to fly to one of what
they're calling the 13 safe states
places that might continue to have
abortion like california or new york but
for a lot of vulnerable women women who
are poor women are women women of color
they will be forced to have
pregnancies that they cannot afford to
terminate and pregnancies that will then
turn into children
the worst kind of pregnancy there is one
that turns into a human child
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message that was a lunatic on the
televised mental institution known as
msnbc
today
is may 4th so uh of course i have to
wish you all a happy may the fourth be
with you that's how we do it here uh
we've got a meme from the may 4th here
we thought this was a good one who wore
it better
that is uh hillary clinton over at the
met gala a couple days ago and there is
someone slightly less evil that's
emperor palpatine uh from the star wars
series disney of course bought that and
ruined that whole thing
but we thought we'd show you that i mean
these people
i had to watch that clip five times this
morning
five times it's like getting hit by a
truck that's where i'm at mentally right
now but some good things did happen
yesterday uh jd vance won the republican
primary in ohio for senator i've had jd
on the show i've met him a couple of
times and look at this
this is something you are not going to
see on mainstream media
trump backed 22 candidates in primaries
that were in ohio and indiana yesterday
every single one
of them won so there is a massive shift
happening politically
unfortunately we're not going to be
talking about that much at a national
level because we got to just do abortion
abortion abortion and just deal with the
endless nonsense related to all of that
um so the theme of the show
today is that look this leak happened on
purpose there's just no doubt we're
gonna find out more about the leak there
are a couple rumors online now i don't
want to get into the rumors of who did
it or how they did it i want to wait
till we have a little bit more
information talk about a responsible guy
on the computer machine that you're
watching i'm going to wait uh till we
have some more info on all of that
however
it is fairly obvious
that the leak was intended to get our
eye off the ball to keep the shell game
of nonsense going to ensure uh that we
would stop talking about say the
ministry of truth remember we were
talking about that a couple days ago say
the supply chain stuff say the gas stuff
say the inflation stuff say the war
stuff etc etc and the point is we cannot
let them get away with it and i am not
going to let them get away with it and i
promise you even though it is very
obvious that the next two months are
just going to be endless abortion and
riots and crazy democrat politicians and
we'll get to some of them in just a
moment uh i am going to keep my eye
focused on the things that actually
matter and that is not to say that the
supreme court decision does not matter
that's not to say we're not going to
cover any of the things related to that
and the things that are important
related to states rights and all those
things but i'm not going to stop
focusing on the actual things that
matter because that's what the system
wants us to do and that's what
everyone's going to do i i can't imagine
that any of you are watching cnn on a
regular basis but i would venture to say
that 80 percent of what they're going to
show today will be abortion related
instead of all of the things that are
happening in all of our day-to-day lives
right that that we've been talking about
here and that you know affect you uh
more than this decision uh so that's
what we're gonna be focusing on how
they're moving
the ball and they're getting our eye off
the ball and how we're not paying
attention to the right things so we're
going to unpack all of the craziness
obviously related to the decision and
the media and the rest of it and then
we're going to show you the things that
they don't want you to see and then
we'll talk a little bit about how you
can fight back and make sure that they
don't pull this trick right in front of
our eyes uh before i get to any of that
i want to talk to you but guys about
alto ira you know crypto may represent
the future of money everyone can kind of
see that right now it's one of the
exciting investment opportunities that
has come around in a long long time but
what about taxes with an alto crypto ira
you can trade crypto like bitcoin and
avoid or defer the taxes there are
multiple ways to fund your account you
can make a cash contribution transfer
cash from an existing ira or even roll
over an old 401k or you can trade all
you want without the tax headache uh
that you can and you can create an
account in just a few minutes ready to
take your investments to the next level
diversify like the pros and trade
without tax headaches open an alto
crypto ira with as little as 10 bucks
just go to alto ira.com
ruben that's a-l-t-o-i-r-a-dot-com
rubin start investing in cryptocurrency
today go to alto ira.com reuben
and now back to
me all right
so first off here is a crazy woman
screaming outside of the supreme court
for decades now and we are gonna fight
back
i saw that five times this morning so
now you have to watch it one more time
for
decades now and we are gonna fight back
all right so uh of course that is fake
indian american fake native american
senator from massachusetts elizabeth
warren she is a far left progressive nut
bag having a nervous breakdown because
uh she thinks that not enough babies are
going to be killed now remember
the reversal or the potential reversal
of roe v wade does not make abortion
illegal most states are going to
continue to allow abortion they will put
some restrictions on it okay and that
will be up to each state just the way it
was before 1973
but this is what the left is that the
reason i'm showing you that it's just
one little moment of her screaming and
trust me there was way more and it's
also very interesting because she's sort
of being held by a by an aide as she's
walking for some reason a lot of these
democrats can't seem to walk alone or
they're always they always seem like
they're about to fall over uh but what
they are doing is doing their fake
outrage thing they're always screaming
they're always angry they always are are
right because they're the loudest and we
have to stop pretending that this works
we have to stop being like oh you're
very upset or you're very angry you must
be right about all of this stuff
because she's basically a complete nut
bag and she should not be listened to
but this is what they're doing they are
making this the hill they want to die on
ironically as we talk about abortion
they want endless abortions at any time
anywhere in the world
and when i showed you that msnbc clip
from a moment ago
it's very clear that they know that
california is obviously going to allow
for abortions new york's going to allow
for abortions plenty of blue states will
allow for abortions and they're even
admitting hey you'll be able to come to
our states for abortions and we'll have
abortion parties and the rest of it and
we can probably get some wonderful
hollywood celebrities to fund abortions
and that will be just just great so the
threat that this is somehow coming for
all of these women or no one will be
able to get abortions or any of these
things regardless of what you feel about
abortion it's just simply not true but
what they have exposed themselves to be
are petulant children who are not
getting their way and that's what we
have to treat them if you what would you
do if a child was just screaming and
stamping their feet and everything else
is the best thing to just give them what
they want or is it to ignore them or
teach them some sort of a lesson i think
i'm not a parent yet
but i think it's the latter uh here is a
lefty progressive democrat sort of an
ancillary squad member pramala jayapal
on cnn saying that godis doesn't even
have the right to make decisions about
these sorts of things
i can tell you this is a stunning
stunning rebuke of precedent
and of the fundamental freedom that
women have to make choices about our own
bodies and our own futures and our own
economic security and the thing is
victor
that
these justices are acting like this is
somehow something that they have the
right to change they do not have the
right to change this which has been
settled law for two generations now of
people who have grown up who have gone
through their 20s in the firm belief
that they can make these decisions about
their own bodies
all right so just to be clear i mean
she's just wrong like that's just a lie
of course the supreme court is allowed
to look at prior decisions and make
current decisions right that's exactly
what they do they reverse course on some
things every now and again they usually
expand rights to people that's generally
what the court has done they reverse
wrong decisions in this case what alito
is writing about and we'll see what the
other briefs are but what alito is
saying is there is no basis in the
constitution that makes abortion a
federal right so all we're doing is
letting it go back to the states because
we have a federal system and states are
supposed to do most of the stuff but
that's what's happening on cnn a
progressive lefty gets on there and just
lies so again if you're just watching
stuff if you're just watching stuff
happen if you're the average person oh
my god elizabeth warren is screaming
about stuff she must be right she's
screaming and she's wearing a pink dress
and everyone around her is so upset they
must kind of be right because they're
screaming and then a few minutes later
you get a progressive to go on there and
completely lie to you
about what the supreme court actually
does and how they analyze the law and
what
over time they're allowed to look at and
decide what decisions are right and what
decisions are wrong this is this is how
the whole freaking thing works but if
you think that msnbc can't stoop lower
than freaking out because a
baby might become a child or because an
embryo might become a child a fetus
might become a child here's a genuine
crazy person i mean i know i joke about
a lot of the crazy people they are crazy
people this guy's name is ellie mistahl
and uh well
take a look
alito's fundamental legal reasoning is
that abortion is not a fundamental right
because it doesn't go back to the
founding because the founding fathers
didn't recognize abortion as a
fundamental right and he's right about
that the founding fathers didn't
recognize abortion as a fundamental
right because the founding fathers were
racist misogynist jerk faces who didn't
believe that women had any rights at all
so of course they didn't believe that
women's had rights to their own bodies
the founding fathers didn't believe that
marital rape was a thing
could it be a thing according to the
founding fathers according to sam elita
so that's the history that sam alito is
is is accessing
first off if you're getting political
analysis from a guy with a head of hair
like that you really should think about
what you're doing he looks like he's
half albert einstein half fat albert
okay that's number one
number two
the founding fathers were jerk faces
that's a good one that's the level of
analysis that's going on over there um
it's just complete ridiculous these
people are are insane
they're they're absolutely insane they
sound like petulant children and again
what do you do when a child is just
freaking out and demanding that they get
whatever it is they want do you give it
to them
and that's the way we have to behave
with these people that really is the way
that we are going to have to behave
going forward with these people because
there aren't going to be any good
arguments there really aren't going to
be any good arguments you can
100
be for abortion
and understand why roe v wade was not
the right choice
and you can also uh be pro-life and
understand that certain states are going
to continue to be pro-choice and accept
that because you believe in the
constitution and you believe in
federalism we are now by this uh by this
ruling we are actually expanding freedom
we're expanding the ability for people
to make choices for themselves uh that's
exactly what's happening here but these
people don't really like freedom well
now here's joe biden and and what was
nice about this is he almost he almost
did it he almost put together a
completely coherent sentence
almost kind of maybe a little i mean so
the idea that we're going to make a
judgment
that
is going to say that
no one can make the judgment to choose
to
abort a child
based on a decision by the supreme court
i think goes way overboard
okay he almost you sort of see what he
kind of was trying to say there but
again the decision does not say no one
can make a decision about abortion the
decision just says it goes back to the
states and the states will make the
decision about abortion and if you want
to get an abortion and you're in a state
that says you can't have an abortion or
you're past the time limit or whatever
then go to california and have your
abortion party and everything else he
just can't even say one straight up
clear honest statement but the question
really is why are they going so crazy
over this why is this the number one
issue for these people now i think it's
partly because the machine just spit
this thing out with this leak and what a
beautiful thing for these guys they
think they have something that can push
them over for the midterms right they
think they can fire up the basin enough
they think they can get all the
blue-haired crazy people and the woke
screaming lunatics to scare enough of
the good liberals to think that the
republicans and the conservatives are
coming for women and the rest of it but
of course you know this and this is the
point this is all covering up for the
absolute disastrous policies that's what
it is but but their their goal is to
make you all think that republicans hate
women and they want to control their
bodies that's what they're going for
that's what they're trying to convince
you all of
we've got more on this in just a second
uh but i want to talk to you guys about
real estate agents i trust uh you know i
was just in dallas a couple days ago and
this is a really fantastic company owned
and started by my man glenn beck because
he wanted to help people
get homes uh in a sensible way and it is
very hard to find a real estate agent
you can trust and we talked about and
he's like dave i think maybe this would
be a great uh sponsor for you because
you're pushing cal uh you're pushing
florida on everybody you're selling
florida although it basically sells
itself and you're trying to get
everybody out of california but you can
buy a home uh in california through
these guys so you guys know this buying
or selling a home is already one of the
most stressful things that you can do
and it can be 10 times worse if you're
not working with the right agent
generally speaking our homes are our
biggest investment and that's a lot of
responsibility and you need an agent
that can take that seriously that's why
i recommend real estate agents i trust
we work with only the best agents in
every market we do our homework talking
to every agent before inviting them to
join our network and here's a big one we
only work with full-time professionals
no part-time or inexperienced agents our
team makes the intro and then follows
you through the buying or selling
process to make sure that you're
satisfied the agents we work with have
long track records and are the best
sellers in their field they're part of
this audience they're part of glenn's
audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
the process is simple just go to real
estate agents
itrust.com today and provide us with
some basic info our team will contact
you to make an introduction and our
preferred agent in your town will reach
out to you
and uh glenn stands by this company
they've done a ton of deals and i'm
psyched to be working with them and now
back to me all right so why would
the democrats be screaming why would all
of these young people be out in the
supreme court steps yelling about things
that they're not sure of and elizabeth
warren screaming and people on msnbc are
calling other people jerk faces and very
upset that fetuses could turn into
babies and freaking everybody out do you
think there might be some reasons for it
because i think that perhaps there are
uh it might have something to do with
the fact that nobody likes joe biden
we've got his approval ratings here and
they're flipping what you can see there
uh right now his approval rating is at
41.5
his disapproval rating uh is at
53.1 percent that is up
11.6 so people over the last little bit
last couple months
as all the prices went up
and it started getting harder to get
stuff and the war that we can't make any
sense of and the rest of it people were
starting to realize that
maybe joe is not the best guy to be in
charge of everything but we've got some
info on inflation in case you think i'm
making this all up in case you think uh
that what you're seeing at your gas
station or at your supermarket is not
legit uh in march 2022 prices had
increased by 8.5
compared to march 2021 according to the
12-month percentage of change in the
consumer price index respectful
respectable respect
respectively
i just pulled a biden right there there
you go the monthly in inflation rates
for goods and services in the united
states
so that's what happens to biden there
you go uh so you can see that the
inflation is not good and of course gas
gas is also a problem uh the current
average price for regular gas right now
four dollars and twenty three cents uh
last month it was four dollars and
nineteen cents last year at this time
2.91
this is what our friends over at uh the
white house called the putin price hike
although i think it has a little
something to do with their policies and
of course speaking of their policies
there are other problems uh here from
the new york times as you may know uh in
terms of foreign policy the taliban have
taken over afghanistan uh remember that
from august where we left that thing and
we just cracked the whole freaking thing
and of course uh russia we've got a
problem with russia why is russia
invaded ukraine and what does putin want
we're not going to be talking about that
anymore because of the abortion thing um
and of course joe biden was also the guy
that right now he's talking about your
body your choice and he doesn't want
anyone coming for women and you're it's
a sacred right and he's always telling
women that as a catholic somehow
abortion is a sacred right for him but
this is the same guy who is enforcing
vaccine mandates on pretty much
everybody
with covet cases surging and deaths now
five times higher than just a month ago
president biden is requiring tens of
millions more americans to get
vaccinated we've been patient
but our patients is wearing thin
and your refusal has cost all of us this
is not about freedom
or personal choice
it's about protecting yourself and those
around you the president is ordering
nearly all federal workers and employees
of contractors that do business with the
federal government get vaccinated within
75 days eliminating their option to be
tested instead of getting shots
employees who refuse could be punished
even fired if you want to work with the
federal government do business with us
get vaccinated while initially reluctant
to issue mandates the president's
aggressive new plan requires
vaccinations for 17 million health care
workers at hospitals and other sites
that receive medicare or medicaid
funding president biden's now pressuring
private companies too directing the
labor department to require businesses
with 100 or more employees ensure their
workers are fully vaccinated or provide
a negative test each week a move the
white house estimates will impact 80
million americans
companies that do not comply could face
fines
okay so the reason that it's important
to show that stuff is because as i
always say we can't forget i mean this
is only a few months ago that they were
demanding everyone get injected with the
stuff that they wanted us to get
injected with they were firing the front
line workers the nurses and doctors and
police officers et cetera et cetera who
they told us were the essential workers
just months before and they were saying
that it's not your body or your choice
that we are going to force you to do
this or you're going to lose your job
you're going to lose your livelihood now
they've taken a complete 180 position on
that and they're it's the reverse now it
is your body of course they're not
really talking to the baby uh they're
just talking uh to the woman well i
don't even know how they're talking to
the woman because i don't think these
people are all biologists but that's a
whole other
thing so
uh well
why would they be doing this why would
they be doing this and and why would
they not want a guy like me to talk
about this sort of thing or a person
like you to watch this sort of thing
well just a few days ago they were all
into this ministry a truth thing and and
suddenly we're not talking about that
either but i'm not going to forget that
and either should you this new report
that the department of uh homeland
security is setting up a disinformation
governance board to tackle
misinformation ahead of the midterms um
secretary marcus
said that part of its intention was to
tackle misinformation in hispanic
communities especially can you give us
an idea of what this board is going to
be doing what their authority would look
like
sure jack i really even dug into this
exactly i mean we of course support this
effort but let me see if i can get more
specifics we know that there has been a
range of disinfo out there about a range
of topics i mean including covid for
example and also elections and
eligibility but i will i will check and
see if there's more specific yeah it's
true lady there has been a lot of
misinformation about covid uh the guy
you work for the guy with dementia or
old person syndrome um he uh was the one
that said that if you get the vaccine
you won't get covet and you won't
transmit covet that was kind of
disinformation
or that there are no side effects and
blah blah blah you get that oh and you
know uh when you say the election thing
there was a lot of disinformation about
elections uh it was you guys that hid
the hunter biden laptop story uh it was
hillary clinton remember the old
coughing lady who um said that donald
trump was an illegitimate president or
you could even go uh to what's her name
over in georgia
stacy abrams that piece of work
who said that the election that she lost
was illegitimate but i'm pretty sure
that's not what you guys mean about
disinformation but the point is they
want us to forget all of the things that
they've lied about so okay now to the
pivot of the show
these people are crazy you get it they
lie about everything you get it so what
do we do about it let's do some answers
ruben report viewers well first what do
we do we actually address the issue head
on we clearly state what the issue is
right now and we don't mince words about
it here
is florida governor and america's
governor ron desantis well look i'm
somebody that believes in pro-life
protections i think that it's something
that is based in science i think it's
something that is based in kind of who
we are as a society i think you look at
what some of the other states are doing
going in a much different direction
where they will have
one day before a baby's born
allow it to be snuffed out nine months
in and i'm just thinking to myself how
is that something that would ever be
viewed to be appropriate and i think
part of the things with this discussion
about some of the supreme court's case
law as it's shown
americans who look at that and then look
at say europe just how out of step the
united states has been and and really
how radical the the jurisprudence has
been compared to a lot of industrialized
countries i mean the us is more
in line with countries like china and
north korea than it is with typical
european countries that are more even
social democracies that we would
consider to be more left-leaning
and yet they have
much more
protection
that's it a clear
honest common sense assessment of what
is going on that the policies that the
democrats now want are insanely
radical and by the way i mentioned this
yesterday just last month florida passed
a law
that would stop abortions at 15 weeks
that is three and a half months the law
will go into effect in july in about two
months from now and there was you
probably didn't even know about it until
yesterday even if you live in florida
you may not have known about it because
it was very little fanfare there was
very little anger on either side because
most people
even if you're pro-life
most people believe there is a tiny
little window there now we can always
debate
is it 12 is it 15 i think you could say
12 easily and some people could say
texas has done six weeks okay and that's
what the states are now going to decide
to do that's that beautiful experiment
thing okay the states will figure out
what to do but the point is they're
going to try to frame ron desantis as
some anti-abortion
radical extremist and this is the guy
who's the head of a state that just
passed a law that said you can do it up
to three and a half months but he's
going to be an extremist to these people
but everything that he said there was
just common sense stuff you can't have
eight-month abortions you can't have
nine-month abortions our policies
are more in line with the bad guys china
north korea etc etc and also isn't it
interesting how
if you contrast the way the democrats
speak
versus the way someone like desantis
speaks they go with emotion it's
constant lying it's outrage they're
always on the verge of tears or they're
outright crying or screaming or calling
someone racist what did the sadness do
there it's like calmly explaining what's
going on here hey can we have some
common sense and that is how we will win
over time in the immediacy of it i know
it doesn't feel as effective because
when someone's screaming at you and
you're calmly just stating your position
it feels like you're losing ground but
the over time i really do think that is
how you win another way that we can win
is to really underscore
their radicalism you can see it in the
way that they behave but their own
positions the radical positions of these
seven eight nine month post-birth
abortions are not popular even within
their own party but the radicals are
running the show
and they're even admitting this
to the second trimester and that's where
public opinion shifts now you've only
got 34 percent who say that abortion in
that time frame should be legal in most
or all cases you've got two-thirds
basically saying it should be illegal in
most or all cases and then you move to
the third trimester and you see an even
more dramatic movement there less than
20 percent believe abortion in the third
trimester should be legal in most or all
cases eight out of ten voters saying it
should be illegal in most
so you get what's going on there even on
msnbc they can't fully all the time
ignore all the stats and the longer that
a pregnancy goes on sane people
don't want that pregnancy to be aborted
and we can always talk about the the
exception cases right we can always talk
about those things the threat to the
woman's life etc etc
but what we're seeing here is that the
the conservative position if you were to
say that ron desantis in florida is a
more conservative place to a republican
place is the that already is the
moderate position he's not saying no
abortions he's literally saying 15 weak
abortions and then you can see that even
on msnbc they're having to admit now
that most people 80 freaking percent
don't want these third trimester
abortions but where are any democrats
saying that show me some please send me
videos and i'll play them tomorrow and
i'll sit here with tape on my mouth i
will gladly do it i promise you that
how else do we beat them you also go out
there and don't
back down when they spout their nonsense
so this is a great video this is msnbc
as well uh where a woman by the name of
marjorie dannon's feller she is the
president of the susan b anthony list
which works to end abortion by electing
leaders in passing pro-life laws she
went on msnbc she heard some complete
nonsense and she pushed back
just to be clear
people who support late-term abortions
do so only if the safety and the life of
the mother this is not true
this is literally not true and i
challenge you i will send you the the
the objective data on this it is
literally not true and i challenge you
to do that work and not just guess
beautiful something good happened on
msnbc i'll send you the data you can't
just say oh women only want third
trimester abortions because of these
crazy uh uh things that might happen
that's actually not true there's all
sorts of reasons why they want it
beautiful moment okay beautiful moment
and from one beautiful moment now i have
to pause everybody we haven't done one
of these in a couple weeks we're about
to show you a clip from the view
everybody make sure you're in your chair
if you need the booze grab it real quick
uh here is whoopi uh and uh you know
it's her body don't touch her body
but i will tell you this is my body
and nobody you you know you got people
telling me i gotta wear a mask or don't
wear a mask or do this everybody wants
to tell me what to do but you won't let
me make my decision about my body you
are not
the person to make that decision my
doctor and my self and my child that's
who makes the decision and what
well you can already see where i'm going
with this one right i mean are we laying
it on a little thick because this is not
what whoopi and the other nut bag
harpies were saying a couple weeks ago
when it came to other people's bodies
and other people's doctors and other
people's medical decisions here is
whoopi yeah so we had to make a law to
make you understand this is how we do it
and i just feel like look i understand
you don't want to wear a mask i don't
want to wear a mask either but i also
don't want to be concerned
when i'm outside that you didn't do what
you were supposed to do yeah and when i
look what 12 and under those 12 and
others they don't get a choice yeah no
they for that reason alone
this should be mandated because the
little ones
you know they're hoping somebody will
say
mommy or daddy will say yeah come on
we're going to go get this because i got
to tell you the seven-year-old that i
live with
it's like is it
am i gonna be okay at school yeah yeah
and i have to lie yeah when i think
they really make this [ __ ] too easy you
know these people are just so ridiculous
so she wanted other people to be
injected she wanted other people to be
masked she was seemingly very concerned
about seven-year-olds she's not very
concerned about seven month births or
pregnancies let's say
uh but okay fine we could have done a
gajillion clips of that or of every one
of those women saying the exact same
thing obviously here was some uh audio
uh
about how the biden administration
really is in some ways even more radical
than what the senators from the democrat
states want when it comes to abortion
first let me say the president's
position is that we need to codify roe
and that is what he has long called on
congress to act on what is also true is
that there has been a vote on the
women's health protection act which
would do exactly that and there were not
even enough votes even if there was no
filibuster to get that
did you get what she just said right
there they want to push this thing
through to codify roe but even with the
filibuster if they blow up the
filibuster right and they only need 50
votes
that they still don't have enough that
means there aren't even enough democrats
to do the radical thing that the biden
administration wants to do so what do we
have to do people in summation we got to
keep exposing these people we got to not
forget what the real issues are we have
to mock them when it's appropriate and
and we have to just build a better
society and and if this is just the
continued sort of
devolution of of where america is at
that we will just live in sort of very
different countries even if
geographically will still be one country
i think that's kind of okay and maybe
that's what this really is all about
because this thing in essence is about
states rights and it's just going to be
super
different california is just going to be
a giant
cesspool of tax high regulation an
abortion fest and a crime fest and a
drug fest and a homeless fest and then
there'll be other places where it'll be
there'll be some room for disagreement
and they'll be pro-life people and
pro-choice people that live there and
we'll have the moderate positions of 15
weeks and we'll have common sense from
our leaders and things like that
that's it but i'm going to continue
covering all the nonsense from the
administration i'm not going to only
focus on this issue
obviously we'll we'll hit it when we
have to and i'll have to when they start
burning cities and everything else we'll
have to cover uh some of that stuff but
we're not going to let them get away
with it and mostly i'm going to try to
focus on on the better things that we
can build that's going to be a little
bit of the challenge uh around here
because i think that's the only way that
we get out of some of this stuff it's
like man two days ago we're talking
about a ministry of truth an assault
on the first amendment unlike anything
in any of our lifetimes and now they've
got us all freaking out that we're
coming for women and that we're somehow
in the hands-made tale it just
ain't true i watch the handmaid's tale
it's worse than this
okay a couple comments from the locals
community nuclear says uh this assault
on the supreme court is just one of them
one more demonstration that the left
will damage any institution in pursuit
of their deranged policies they are
hoping to intimidate the justice
justices into backing away from their
decision on roe yeah look they don't
like the institutions they don't like
america that is a sad truth that i think
we have to accept they constantly are
telling us this place is racist it was
founded by racists capitalism is evil uh
they want equity more than equality all
of the institutions are rotten and all
of those things and if you don't get
what you want as a leftist what do you
do you either burn them down or you
significantly alter them you pack the
court you say oh the court has a certain
amount of people in it i want more
people i don't like the nine because we
keep losing with the nine so let's get
this thing to 12 and we'll get an extra
couple people in there and they'll vote
and then you know what then it'll happen
the other way they they want a reckoning
of everything we have to accept that and
understand that and that's why if you
just try to rationalize with these
people if you just try to calmly explain
what laws are and what decency is and
what logic and reason are you will
always lose because they will always
continue to march on so what can you do
then do you want to be as hysterical and
insane as them and do all the awful
things that they do or do you want to
just separate hey guys
you can have some stuff i wish you
couldn't have all that stuff and it
sucks that you took california it really
does
and it sucks that you've wrought such
destruction okay fine but you did so now
let's just go build some other things
you guys know what i feel about this uh
cat says and just like that the left
knows what a woman is isn't that
extraordinary we just confirmed a
supreme court justice who didn't know
what a woman was she wasn't a biologist
now everybody
everyone's a biologist congratulations
everybody everyone's a biologist today
pat says another california vacate
vacation package abort your baby and
spend the rest of the day looting
walgreens in san francisco
anything's possible
in the dystopian state
of california
mamma mia all right guys uh i hope this
offered you a little bit of sanity i
think i mentioned to you yesterday that
one of the best things about being on
tour uh one of the kindest and and most
consistent things that people would say
to me when they'd come up to me at the
meet and greets was that i helped keep
him sane over two years
it's a two-way street you guys are
helping keeping me sane i'm hopefully
helping keep you sane and uh we're gonna
need a little more of that so let's just
keep going uh part one of my interview
with former uh cia operative officer
brian dean wright really fascinating guy
is up right now on locals and rumble the
whole thing is up
on locals i'm sorry on rumble and
youtube the full thing is up of course
already at locals and uh i think you're
going to enjoy
our cold clothes for today adios
what are you doing here we figured you
know people in the white house
work long hours and maybe i take over
the press briefing thing does that sound
like a good idea that sounds really good
really are you ready my hunch is
this whole thing is just a walk in the
park maybe i can write you some notes
war
with russia well bad keep it like jen uh
cdc
good
really they've been pissing me off
economy
strong
[Music]
iran diplomacy good diplomacy good what
if i get asked about
kim and pete
uh we love love around here so i think
that's a safe place to be
is this real life